hello my name is Esther quarry and today
I'll be giving a talk on introducing
Hadamard binary yo networks
all right good afternoon everyone my
name is Josh Akari and I'll be talking
about well I'll be introducing Hadamard
binary neural networks let's get started
so the contents of the Stockwood we'll
begin by understanding and trying to
demystify parallel and distributed deep
learning then I'll offer a solution for
parallel deep learning which is binary
neural networks and I will work upon how
I engineered it slightly differently and
I'll talk about Hardware binaries in
your networks its performance and its
performance benchmarking so let's get
started so I think it's important to
address the rise and distributed deep
learning and as we can see as ears
progress the number of Ettore reported
the percentage of reported experiments
in the field of AI there's a consistent
rise in the percentage of experiments
that actually report using multiple
nodes and we also see a rise in the
number of experiments that report using
Intel MPI and that essentially indicates
that distributed training is on the rise
however there are a few principal issues
with this methodology Oh let's
distribute the deep learning as the
batch size increases we observe a
decrease and accuracy
obviously this happens after around 512
where the bat size increases about 5
million 12 and this poses a issue in
distributed deep learning because when
there are many nodes we will have to
inherently increase the bat size for
training and also we observe that layers
such as fully connected and
convolutional layers they scale non
linearly but be one perfect scaling a
perfect linear scaling for our
applications so to do this they're
binary neural networks is one way to go
about it what binary neural networks 2
is we take the weights and the
activation matrices and we take the mean
of the absolute value and we multiply
that with the sine function of that
matrix so if you can see here that the
out 3 line 3 is actually a random matrix
which will be your rates or activations
and it has been binarized in our output
line 4 so once we
who this we can actually remove the full
precision number which in this case is
0.47 four and we have a binary matrix
which only has two values plus one and
minus one we can cast the minus ones
into a zero and we can bit packet into
available datatypes 32-bit data type
16-bit data type and then we can use bit
manipulations to do the forward pass
instead of or you know FMA operations
and this actually speeds up the
inference significantly so we can
benefit a lot in terms of you know the
amount of memory access because this is
significantly reduced here however this
has this actually has a problem that
matrices you know typically your
networks are of the order of 4096 4096
or even larger and once we binarize it
in such a destructive fashion we lose
out on a lot of the accuracy which is
quite important and that is that is the
endgame actually so how can we increase
the capacity of such a neural network we
can either increase the bit width of
every element in the matrix or we can
actually create a new way of binarize
elimin I do not binarize the entire
matrix in one go i segment the given
matrix so I will demonstrate how we
actually do harder mud or binarization
so just give me a second we initialize a
random real matrix of three by nine and
I binarize it in this function and you
can see that HP grad forward W comma
four four here is the binarization
agression that is essentially the number
of elements i binarize row wise so you
can see that after binarized
get zero point nine three as the first
four elements of the first row and so on
and what i can do is i can factorize
this into two matrices one of them
binary and the other a full precision
matrix the binary matrix can again be
compressed 32 times if you pack it into
an unsigned it and if you can compress
the full precision matrix four times or
basically what the binarization
aggression is so this is a very
adaptable method to actually constrain
the network and
kind of preserve its accuracy and we can
aim for you know high-end GPUs CPUs or
levan GPUs and buy the devices by
increasing the binarization aggression
to make it more friendly to low powered
hardware and but why does this exactly
work so since neural networks the
gradient descent is a you know it has a
long a lot of a directionality involved
so the best way to study it in my
opinion is doing some high dimensional
analysis so what I did was I initialized
a random vector of size 64 comma 512 and
then I use Hadamard binarization for
several binarization aggressions and
once I plotted that for binarization
aggression from 2 to about 512 I
observed that the angle between the full
precision matrix and the hard mode
binarized matrix converges to around 37
point 5 degrees as the matrix size
approaches infinity so 37 degrees is
considered to be pretty small in a very
high dimensional space but as I decrease
the binarization aggression as I go
towards maybe for element binder izing
for elements at a time I observe that
the angle comes down to about 25 to 30
degrees so that is why this method
inherently works better than a typical
binder of vanilla binarization technique
which I discussed in the earlier slide
so I guess I have explained why the
forward propagation is you know
efficient but the back propagation is
also an important part of training and
to to explain why with this algorithm
back propagation will be pretty
efficient I present the algorithm
basically the equation which will
calculate the gradients through the
binarization and we can see that the
Delta which is being calculated is the
absolute value of the HB grad forward
which is calculated anyway so we can
just save that and reference that again
during back propagation and while
calculating the greedy gradient you can
see Dow C by Dow the blue till by times
this derivative of the sine function I
can simply use a clipping function
because I use a linear estimator from
minus 1 to 1
for the derivative of the sine function
so this is a very efficient way to back
propagate through the network and we
save a lot of memory memory accesses as
well as a computation time because
there's no actual fuse FMA operations
who has better happening unless I you
know I had just open a benign binarize
ation aggression to do my needs
I'm sorry so how do i binarize
convolutions well i've I have discussed
how I can binarize you know matrix
multiplication but convolutions are a
different matter altogether because the
kernels are usually of the size 3 by 3
or 5 by 5 and I'm sorry but I don't know
why the convolution Jeff is not
stabilizing but you can see that this is
essentially how convolution happens so
our kernel slides over the given
activations which are coming from the
previous layer to calculate the next
layer so to make this more efficient
what I do is I use the I am to call
methodology in the sense that we can
transform the image data and the filter
data in a given fashion to convert the
entire convolution operation to a
general matrix multiplication operation
and once I do that I can again use the
binarization methodology of offer matrix
and this is the flow chart which
actually explains the entire process the
image uses the I M to call methodology
and the weights uses a simple reshape
and then active is the binarization
function itself and once I have
binarized the unrolled matrices I can
simply multiply that using my optimized
gem kernels and then I can just reshape
that for the output so this is the this
is essentially how the entire network
will function I'm sorry but now let's
discuss performance how well does it
actually perform in a real-world
scenario so I tested this on the amnesty
to set and C 410 dataset using the
Linnet architecture from cafe and Aleks
net inspired Network which has been this
is a follow up work on Matthew
roxas work on binary connect and if you
are interested I'm sorry if you're
interested you can look at how the
network layout is and so the results for
binarization the the speed-up we get is
proportional to 1 by the binarization
accuracy binarization aggression plus 1
by 32 32 being the bit the data type I
choose to the bit width of the data type
I choose to pack this into so for B is
equal to which is the binarization
aggression equal to 4 I observe that for
M Ness it actually outperforms the full
precision network and it also
outperforms the X nor net architecture
which is the latest reported accuracy
results from you know academia and we
also observe that see far 10 the Alex
and inspired architecture for B is equal
to 4 and B is equal to 8
both outperform X nor net I was not able
to complete the test for B is equal to
16 and time because of the training
constraints and the full precision
network well it's it's much better than
the X nor network but it surely could we
could actually try for B is equal to 2
maybe it could out from the full
precision network so now let's discuss
the high performance kernels which I
have attempted to create using C and
Intel openmp so gem is a general matrix
multiplication operation C MMA is the
same thing classic matrix multiplication
algorithm and x HB n n is the general
matrix multiply for the Hadamard binary
neural network so C MMA has been C MMA
and xh b NN must be noted have been
similarly optimized and obviously
variable scroll MK l is Intel MKL which
has been optimized by several research
scientists for decades and we can see
here that the Y ax
this is logarithmic and CMM a is taking
significantly longer than xh b NN for
beta or binarization aggression equal to
16 this is on the order of 10 to 30 x +
4 m KL well with the best I could do as
a student I have seen that x HB n n
actually performs at par or sometimes a
bit better than MK l and I think that
concludes the analysis of x HB n n as
well as the accuracy benchmarks and if
anyone has any questions regarding this
framework or the algorithm I'll be happy
to answer that
[Applause]